max are back oh yeah vaccine combo
you gotta have your max bruh okay
we gotta have uh you gotta start wearing
macs again so
so news popped up uh the comedy store is
basically
kind of like uh trying to motivate
people to
get vaccinated the audience as well
they're going
only vaccinated for the audience yeah
and uh and comics
and employees and comics and employees
and this made news
and i'll say back here in new york the
comedy seller's already been like this
everybody's got to be vaccinated the
audience has got to be vaccinated
um and it was funny there was like no
black people in the crowd the first few
times i went on stage and i'm like oh is
this the new like no
fitted hat no temperatures that's how
you keep black people out of
establishments like you don't even have
to talk about their clothes
yeah no do-rags no service no no just
say vaccine and then boom you're
you're gonna have a very white asian
indian
that's white panther that's white
panther so
uh so yeah so so now comedy store
in la is doing it and people are making
a big deal of this but i think this is
what's gonna happen
i think because the government can't say
you have to get vaccinated
because the government can't say you
have to wear a mask they can't just
because of the way that
the american justice system is built
they can't just say that
there are liberties private businesses
can take it upon themselves to decide
what the policy is
yeah and that's just what's going to
happen the corporations are going to go
you want to work here you're going to
have to be vaccinated yeah
how do you guys feel about it i didn't
have a problem 10 years ago when the
christian guy was like hey i'm not
making your gay wedding cake
it's not it's something i believe is
christian i didn't agree with the moral
stance but it is a private business
and a lot of people who probably are
gonna have a problem with this were like
nah that guy should have a right to
conduct business as he wants to but then
they have an issue
with people requiring mass and vice
versa people who before like no he
should have to make that gay wedding
cake
it doesn't matter this is a business
blah blah blah whatever their logic was
they're going to support this and say oh
no
it's a private business now you should
be allowed to keep out people who are
unvaccinated
i think on both sides you keep your
business do what you want to do conduct
it how you'd like
right yeah from a consumer level i agree
from like an employment level i think
it's tricky
like if the if the shop was like
discriminating hiring people
for being gay then i'd be like oh no
that's [ __ ] yes agreed
i think that should be illegal to not
hire someone just basically like their
orientation whereas like making a cake
is like oh that's just a consumer
yeah and so i think you're able to pick
and choose consumption but as far as
like employment i feel like that's
different
right interesting though yeah that is
interesting but for the vaccine do you
feel the same sorry do you feel the same
consistency like
because i think there is a difference if
it's like this guy could infect me or my
customers or whatever so no it can't
affect you as your vaccine yeah it's
true that's true actually but private
companies already have rules for
their employment like there are some
drug tests some don't
right so it's like that's based on a
private uh company so yeah
and it is a choice vaccines as well
right and now we're at a stage where
people with a delta variant for
vaccinated folks and unback saying folks
the spread is
is the same so that's not true that's
not true that's apparently that's
medium misinformation apparently it's
like is it yeah the biden administration
is mad at the media now
oh are they yeah yeah now the news is
fake okay another thing i'm upset about
that i discovered in
europe where i just was yeah alavanting
is that
they have this european green pass
just just banting that if you actually
get credit
for being a covid survivor as we all are
for six months
not like nine within 90 days we have to
go race over to cvs and and get the
vaccine
why are we not looking at yeah natural
protection
it's look it's tricky it's uh annoying
um i'm not annoyed as much about
the vaccine thing being mandatory
because i've taken it
so it affects me in no way uh
if i i don't know why like i understand
that people are really
concerned about the vaccine and they
think that it's really awful and
something's going to happen
it's an experiment yes that might be the
case um
but i don't know for whatever reason if
i'm being completely honest with you i'm
just like
whatever i really just feel whatever
about it at this point
because i've taken it already no my arm
could fall off in six months that's
possible
and then you guys call me a [ __ ]
idiot and i'll be competing in the
special olympics
just killing these [ __ ] right
working that nose paralympics yeah
exactly i point that [ __ ] up there
that's the rudder yeah
that's the rudder uh but i i i'm just
like
i'm i don't care if you take it or not
i'm not gonna be one of these people
who's gonna go you need to get the
vaccine i don't give a
flying [ __ ] if you take it or not but i
also don't give a flying [ __ ] if you die
from covet agreed yeah
now if you take the vaccine and you die
from covid
i'm furious yeah because why are we
doing this experimental [ __ ] and then
we're still doing i'm dying anyway
but that's not happening yes the numbers
are showing that that's not happening
the death rates haven't changed no the
vaccine's effective
the vaccine is effective it's definitely
effective uh when it comes to dealing
with the virus in your system so it
makes it much easier to deal with
like i know somebody who got the delta
variant she didn't have the vaccine
and it [ __ ] roasted her up it was
really bad and she had the original one
so corona ran it back with her with that
delta and she said it was way worse
but if she had the vaccine she would
have plowed through that [ __ ] or she
wouldn't even got infected there are
some so
max people are like yo it's you can
still die from delta with the vaccine
but it's like
less than a half a percent it's like
point zero zero one percent
are dying from it and then most of those
people either have like something
comorbidities
which this is my point about this this
might be stop making policy based on
[ __ ] that are fat like stop it
and also stop stop stop making clothes
for them stop doing everything for them
no no no no no no please make clothes
for them no no i don't want no
naked fat people walking around i want
that squeezing out like a sausage
yeah in terms of the mask mandate you
cannot
the flu kills more than point zero zero
one percent of people who get it
we don't have a mask mandate in place
for the flu you can't have a mask
mandate based on point zero zero one
percent of people who are dying
or people who have made a choice that
they were allowed to make which is i
don't wanna get this vaccine i also
think at the same time a business has a
right to say i have a choice and say
fine you can't come into my business and
if you die we don't give a [ __ ] but i
don't want that choice to be that we
wear a mess
i'm over the mask yeah i'm not wearing
this anymore i got the vaccine if you
get the vaccine you don't have to wear
the mask and that's it i'm [ __ ] sorry
but that actually i'm not even sorry
that's it i got the [ __ ] in my arm i'm
not wearing the [ __ ] mask
the only pushback and this is what i
heard it could be incorrect knowledge
but i heard that so
because you're getting the vaccine in
the muscle um you're building
up your immune system but it's not like
building up in your nostrils where most
people are
contracting i'm telling you it's like
the delta variant
it the it multiplies way quicker than
the original one
and so you don't have enough [ __ ]
immune system to fight alone
viral load in your nose too that's why
people are getting it still
but you're not dying if you're yeah if
that's the key if you're getting it and
you get sick like you do with the flu
we don't have mandatory flu vaccine or
food that's why they're saying you
should still wear a mask
you can suggest it and i can say [ __ ]
you yeah
i guess yeah we're not doing a mashup
we're not doing the math that's what i'm
saying i think at a certain point like
you got to move on like there's an
effective vaccine that's out
it's been out long enough for people to
get it it's free for people
to get it and at a certain point you got
to be like all right let's keep them and
we have effective treatments when people
do get it that's the other thing like
you know how to handle it i don't care
about cases anymore i care about death
rates
rate hospitalization is down everywhere
if the death rate's down and the
hospitals aren't overflowing then we're
good to go shut your [ __ ] mouth and
go about business as usual i'm sorry
stop doing this [ __ ] where you like
create legislation to make it seem like
you give a flying [ __ ] about saving
people's lives when nobody's dying
yeah the death rate is not changing
until it changes
shut your [ __ ] mouth don't tell us to
wear the mask i don't want to seem like
i'm one of these like
carrots outside of a kroger's just like
waiting to see if someone asked me to
put a mask
that's what that's about i took the risk
yeah
i put my life on the line quote unquote
i don't believe
that that's the case but like i put the
[ __ ] in my body
yeah based on a contract that if i put
it in my body
i can go back to life as normal don't
break that contract well said
and do not break it from [ __ ]
that are willing to risk
getting it yeah like you're protecting
people who don't want to be protected
yeah if kids started dying every two
seconds of this [ __ ] i'd be the first
person to have it on trust me
i'd be the first person they're not
dying yeah only people are dying
are the [ __ ] there fuse refuse
to get the vaccine
and if they do have the vaccine they are
on death's doorstep already
yeah and this [ __ ] is just pushing them
off like that [ __ ] game with the
quarters that are at the edge
you know what i'm talking about the
token [ __ ] in coney island not only
you're protecting people who don't want
to be protected you're doing it at our
expense
they've decided they don't want to be
protected and now you are having us make
sacrifices
that we specifically got this vaccine to
not make yeah
you